when you stand in front of the mirror
and instead of going god my jowls look
like saddle bags and i'm today because
my to-do list is so long and you know
and i shouldn't have had that da da da
da da
that sets your mind and your day on a
certain course when you walk into the
bathroom and you have it stack this
simple high five along with brushing
your teeth you are starting your day by
fulfilling your most important needs you
see yourself you affirm yourself you
celebrate yourself and for those of you
that feel stuck
part of your problem is you are
withholding that from yourself until you
get to the number of the scale until you
get that job until you do the thing
you're supposed to do and what you are
doing is backwards you need support
celebration and acknowledgement now in
order to hit that number on the scale
you see most of us believe we're not
worthy of celebration until we achieve
something and i'm here to tell you if
you start celebrating supporting
yourself
as you are every single day
it will become a part of who you are
which empowers and equips you to face
the things and more importantly empowers
and equips you to do the things that
scare you that you need to do and so i'm
on a mission
to
get people to understand that it's only
through small habits
of support
celebration and love
that you will
achieve the happiness
the peace the healing the success the
fulfillment that you're seeking
you can't withhold that from yourself
the first habit that i use at least once
a day is the five second rule
and you all know it you count backwards
five four three two one and the counting
backwards acts like a giant push to help
you push through resignation self-doubt
insecurity whatever it is that the
momentary block or hesitation is
54321
always gets the job done for me and i
use it once every day because true story
i know many of you have heard me say
this but i invented the five second rule
13 years ago
to get out of bed during one of the
worst moments of my life
thirteen years later
i still use it five four three two one
to get out of bed and i think evan you
were talking about this um
i can't i think i saw this in a training
that you did or one of your videos or
maybe we talked about this on our
instagram live
you know there's all this research
about um the fact that if you repeat a
behavior for a certain number of days
that um
it'll become a habit
that may be true
but i believe that if you don't like
doing it
it may never
become something that's automatic and
that's why i love the five second rule
13 years later everybody i still hate to
get out of bed
i know intellectually lying in bed is
the worst place for me to be i know
intellectually laying there and thinking
about the day worst place to be i know
intellectually i should get out of bed i
know the research about the snooze alarm
and not hitting it but i still don't
like to and so i still 13 years later
everybody feel resistance every morning
when the alarm rings so every day i use
the five second rule 54321
to get out of bed
and oftentimes i use the five second
rule 54321 to exercise
um i also use the five second rule five
four three two one to put my phone down
and put it in a basket in our kitchen so
that i don't live in what psychologists
call the gray zone which is where your
phone is on you all the time and you're
you know in your life never able to
disconnect
want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel is created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn the
habits to reprogram your life for
success
enjoy
[Music]
habit number two prime yourself with
tony robbins i changed my body radically
and i do three things to make sure that
my brain is primed and what i mean by
primed is
most people think their thoughts are
their thoughts louis and you and i know
better because you and i have read the
studies right priming is a psychological
principle where
you think thoughts you think they're
yours but very often they're created by
the environment so one example was
harvard has done multiple studies on
this so one of the studies they did
was taking people walking up to people
they hired two actors they walked up to
a hundred people they had do the exact
same thing men and women and what they
did is they walk up with a cup of coffee
in their hand and they'd look at you and
go here we do all this for a second and
look down and reach in their pocket to
pull out their phone
and most people then take the coffee
there's nobody there you're not looking
to give it back right
and then they
do what they're doing the phone they put
it back in they go thank you so much and
they take their coffee back and they
walk away
but then about 20 minutes later if
you're in a mall or school campus or
whatever a person comes by with a
clipboard and they give you twenty
dollars and they say listen i know this
sounds crazy but if you'll give me 30
seconds of your time the 20 is yours i
need you to read two minutes of this
literally this little story and then
just answer three questions for me
here's the interesting part
half the people
have a reaction more than 80 percent and
half have a reaction 80 percent
difference and here's the question they
read the same story
but half the people are handed hot
coffee
half the people handed iced coffee
and the question they ask is how would
you describe the main character of the
story after they read a few paragraphs
and the people who are handed hot coffee
say the person is warm and genuine 81 of
the people
79 to 80 79.8 it's almost it's a one
percent difference you know natural
variability who are given the iced
coffee see the person is cold and
uncaring i can tell you 20 studies like
that that would blow your mind how your
brain is conditioned or primed by the
environment and think about all that's
gone on with covert of the last two
years and how many people's brains live
in fear and in my new health book i put
in there just to remind people with
covid outside being 80 years old the
number one or having four or five
comorbidities number one factor eighty
percent of people die of cove at seventy
nine point eight percent
are obese that's something you can do
something about the second factor
according to the cdc is fear
because anxiety makes people get short
of breath they freak out and their whole
nervous system starts to go shut down
your immune system can be shut down just
by fear alone
and so this experience of life that we
have most people just don't understand
that you are being primed all the time
and unless you prime yourself you're
going to be primed by the environment
which most people understand that your
brain right now is being conditioned and
triggered whether you know it or not if
you're in any social network it's being
done continuously by algorithms so i
want to take control of my brain so i do
three quick things one
i take three minutes of those 10 minutes
after i've changed my body and i focus
on three different events in my life
that i'm grateful for i usually pick two
big ones and one small one it could be
as simple as a smile my daughter's face
uh the wind against you know my skin but
i really i don't like if you ever been
on a roller coaster and you remember the
roller coaster over there it's not the
same as remember going over the edge
like you're there so i do it in an
associated way and it changes your
biochemistry now it sounds pretty you
know positive thinking i'm going to be
grateful
but there's a value to it because the
two emotions that mess up your business
your life your relationships are anger
and fear
and you can't be angry and grateful
simultaneously
and you can't be fearful and grateful
simultaneously so by starting my day
with that and it's not some fake pump up
positive thinking they're real
experiences so it literally teaches your
body to go in that state because
otherwise the environment when right now
there's a whole lot of uncertainty and
fear then real fast i do this
three-minute process it's kind of like a
blessing and then three minutes the last
three minutes are called three to thrive
where i focus on three things i want to
accomplish but instead of thinking i
want to accomplish i see feel and
experience it is done i feel grateful i
celebrate it and it trains your brain so
in 10 minutes i'm done third thing that
i'll do i immediately send a message or
a text or an audio message to somebody
as a sincere compliment and i don't go
dude great job or wow you're cool i say
listen i saw you on tuesday with those
kids and i saw you take that extra 20
minutes no one else did i just want you
know i saw that i thought that was
incredible so i'm always very specific
so they know it's not just some positive
thinking [ __ ] call it's sincerely
doing and it makes me constantly look
for the good in the people i work with
fourth thing i do is whatever i don't
want to do the most challenging part of
the day i want to go handle that problem
i want to handle that issue because
after you do that everything has
momentum so those four are my core habit
number three get rid of negative
thoughts with grant cardone get rid
literally get rid of all the negative
automatic
negative out of control thinking that
anybody has
i got to get people to like me that's a
negative comment i don't have to get
people to like me you know people either
like me they don't i need to lose weight
okay if i can do this you can do this
but it's going to be hard if you don't
change your mind you got to change
you got to change the way you think
and a way to change the way you think
ultimately there's two ways okay i mean
there's probably three or four ways but
first of all the one way is to start
discipline yourself catch yourself every
time you say i don't have time
say hey i create time
every time you say i don't have money i
create money
um or maybe just start just start
literally like talking to yourself that
hey i am a millionaire i am a
multi-millionaire i own
if you want to if you're in the
apartment game and you want to be in
apartments but you don't know anything
about apartments you can start literally
talking to yourself saying i am worth
uh or i own 100 units i did this for
years for years before i ever bought an
apartment i used to write down i own 20
apartments that earns 12 percent cash
flow second thing is if you want to
permanently get rid
of the negative parts in your mind
send me an email to help
at grantcardone.com and put in
uh mind m-i-n-d okay i'm gonna turn you
on to something i did i'm not gonna go
into it here it's just too deep it's too
much it's too heavy it's too simple
frankly for anybody to even
even uh
even get because most people most people
believe they're stuck
with their thinking like it's yours
permanently and you gotta you gotta push
and shove and you gotta discipline
yourself every day what if you could
just get rid of it
okay i'm not talking about hypnosis i'm
not talking about
you know uh
drugs
doing mushrooms i heard a guy the other
day talking about how
he did uh
he experimented with mushrooms to
to to make himself brighter another guy
put peppermint in his ears to make him
smarter i'm like dude you guys got to be
kidding
okay come on
come on man come on really
if you have to take something to make
you smarter look get rid of whatever's
making you dumber
just get rid of it you shouldn't have to
add something
you should not have to add something to
make you smarter you should not have to
add something to make you faster
you should remove whatever is slowing
you down
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there habit number four get momentum
with brendon burchard when you are super
down
outside of finding that emotional
reasoning for where you are
is to start getting momentum because
with momentum comes hope with momentum
comes motivation with momentum comes
you know that feeling that there's a
reason for tomorrow
and so it's as simple as just saying
okay what are three things i'm gonna do
today
and
i don't mean that like a lot of personal
development guys would say like what are
your three big goals for the day
i'm like dude sometimes that first goal
is
shh i'm gonna shower today
i'm really in shower today
uh
i'm gonna walk to the library
and come home
and that's all they got
like literally that's all they got
and you gotta honor that struggle
when you're in that place like know that
where you're at it is okay that you're
there and now you're gonna need help and
now you're gonna have to set up some
daily practices just every day win a
little bit
not like win your dreams not like crush
through goals not like be badass not
like no
just momentum man get some momentum and
be okay if that momentum is really small
because it will build trust that that
momentum builds and trust those
gloomy and bad dark days
trust that those are going to be there
they'll get less and less and less as
you learn how to cope but they're going
to be there and so when they're there
it's one of my i mean outside of
teaching people to bring the joy in my
life
i teach people to honor the struggle
honor the difficulty
when we honor the struggle instead of
hate the struggle
we can really achieve extraordinary
things because our mindset's in the
right place it accept like as soon as
you honor the struggle you accept that
oh of course there should be struggle
here i should i should honor this
process when you go to the gym to work
out you like honor that this is going to
be hard and it honored that process of
getting better and the more that you
bring honor to it the more your psyche
builds with strength and you get a
little bit of that esteem back
because you see yourself engaging
something versus avoiding it and running
away
you see yourself connecting with
something and giving it
reverence
you're like like i have reverence for
the difficulties of life they may be
better
so i i don't want a friction free life
i'm not interested in it you know the
the the
i like to say sometimes that you know
the journey to greatness begins
the moment that
our you know deep desires for comfort
and ease
are overpowered
by our desires to connect and contribute
habit number five become confident with
jay shetty the first thing that
confident people do is that they work
through their past often
our anxiety and insecurity comes not
from where we are now but what we've
been through before we think that what
we went through was something we
deserved or we feel what we went through
defines who we are today and that makes
us feel a lack of confidence
confident people however
don't let their past live as it is they
try to make sense of it they try to
learn how they can navigate through
those past experiences and see how
they've been affected i want to share
with you a really practical activity you
can do what are the gifts that you
received from your parents what are the
skills what are the qualities what are
the abilities that you gained from their
parenting
when you realize that you're already
reaffirming the definition
as you learn to assure yourselves and
become confident about the abilities and
qualities you have you're creating
confidence
now i also want you to reflect on what
you believe are the gaps that you may
have received from your background what
are the areas of your life that you feel
you missed out on that make you feel
insecure when you understand that you
start to recognize that this isn't a gap
in you it's a gap or a hole in your
experience now remember you can always
improve your experience you can always
improve yourself but first we have to
conquer the past by trying to understand
it the second way to develop confidence
is to construct a high value skill when
we have a high value skill we learn to
value ourselves and we don't let other
people dictate our value a lot of the
time we don't feel confident is because
we don't feel we have something to offer
but here's the thing each and every
person has a genius and has unique
potential but we have to turn that
potential into an expertise through
practice for me i remember being an
extremely shy kid growing up my parents
forced me to go to public speaking and
drama school from age 11 through to age
18. i realized that as i developed the
skill to articulate and communicate
effectively it allowed me to be more
confident
and then my confidence was gained when i
learned through the vedas when i lived
with the monks and learned how to
meditate as soon as you start to learn a
high value skill you start to develop
your confidence young people especially
struggle because they feel like a
generalist they feel like they're okay
at everything when we can actually focus
on mastery we start to develop
confidence and this is a healthy way of
developing confidence because in the
pursuit of mastery you will overcome
lots of challenges you will have to
develop resilience you'll actually have
to deal with setback and failure
now your confidence is not based on
arrogance or cockiness your confidence
is based on your ability to deal with
challenging situations your skill could
be anything
marketing technology acting singing web
design photography videography the list
goes on i want you to schedule your next
four weekends to be experimenting with a
new skill or a new class or workshop
then based on that i want you to decide
which one you may want to turn into a
high value skill the more you experience
the more you explore the more you allow
yourself to be exposed to the more
likely you're going to find something
that you want to turn into expertise the
next step is to constantly learn
now this may sound like a lot of work
but actually learning can be something
that gives you a sense of achievement
sense of drive sense of momentum and a
feeling like you're moving forward and
towards something when you dabble in
articles books podcasts you start to
feel this sense of being alive you have
something to share in every conversation
you have something to add you are more
inclined to listen to learn more and see
how your idea develops confidence comes
from the ability to engage in a
conversation and the feeling that you're
moving forward the feeling that you
don't feel stuck or trapped in a space
learning and consistently learning can
truly transform the way you feel about
yourself you start to trust yourself you
think to yourself wow i remember this
from what i read last week i was able to
apply that idea at work today when you
start to connect the dots around what
you're learning and what you're growing
in that makes you feel a sense of
confidence one of my favorite ways to
practice this method is by using the
blinkist app you can learn so much from
over 4 000 non-fiction books that
they've simplified into short blinks
these blinks help you understand the
summary and the essence of each book
that exists on the platform you can also
listen to the blinks if you're traveling
or moving around or prefer not to read
the fourth step is to be compassionate
when you're compassionate toward
yourself you give yourself a break for
not knowing everything or getting
everything right all the time i used to
think
that if every time a client asked me a
question i could give the perfect best
most powerful answer then that was what
made me valuable
i started to realize that i couldn't fix
someone's problems through an answer i
started to recognize that listening
understanding creating content that
allowed me to think more broadly and
deeply was actually going to be more
useful to someone when they could make
sense of it themselves
having compassion for myself and
realizing i didn't have to be perfect
all the time which is impossible for
each and every person allowed me to
actually find my unique potential and my
clients what they really enjoyed was the
conversation that came out of it not
that they were impressed by a speedy
response remember it's not about being
perfect confidence shows that you're
okay with being wrong you're okay with
not knowing and you're okay with
desiring to learn and research so you
can expand your skills usually when
people work hard they become more
hard-hearted they become more cold they
start to judge people more because they
think they're doing more than others but
when you work hard for the right purpose
and the right reasons you actually
become more soft-hearted that
soft-heartedness makes you more
compassionate and empathetic to
realizing if you've had to work so hard
imagine how difficult it is for others
you start to understand their journey
better the next step is called calm
responses confidence comes not from
reacting fast but responding slowly
sometimes the person who speaks the
least their opinion matters the most
because they're not saying a lot they're
listening processing and then responding
and when they speak
people listen
why because they don't waste words they
don't come across hasty they've
genuinely thought about everyone's
opinion in the room they've taken the
time to process it
remember less is more be mindful and
calm in your responses
take a moment and respond at the pace of
love or the rhythm of love don't act out
of force or haste how can you feel
confident if you feel rushed if you feel
forced to say something go at your own
pace in your own time
a lot of the time we don't feel
confident because we're desperately
seeking validation from others we always
ask ourselves what will people say what
would they think how would they react to
what i feel
and the challenge is that we've been
trained to ask everyone everything from
when we try on a new jacket or a new
coat and we look at our friend family
member or partner we say what do you
think i look in this confidence comes
from asking yourself that question how
do i feel i look in this often we
message our friends and family and say
where do you want to go for dinner
tonight what would you like to do
it's really important that we also get
to know ourselves and ask ourselves what
would i like to do when we start to find
certainty and awareness around our likes
and dislikes what we feel works for us
and what doesn't work for us that builds
a sense of confidence
usually when we spend time with a lot of
people we hear a lot of noises we hear a
lot of ideas opinions expectations and
even obligations
but when you start to find time with
yourself you can ask yourself deeper
questions ask yourself how you truly
feel about something and what your
genuine beliefs are then you can act on
that internal certainty rather than all
of the external uncertainty and finally
the people that are confident are
confident because they competently
prepare
preparation is so underestimated in
every field if you're confident it's not
because you just have a sense of self
belief it's not just because you act it
it's because you practiced prepared and
worked you've planned you've visualized
you've prepared your energy you've
prepared your mindset that's why the
development of daily habits allows us to
get there habit number six take control
of your morning with ed mylett i changed
what i did in the morning and i changed
what i did in the evening and so somehow
by grabbing control of my morning and by
grabbing control of my evening i got
some measure of control over the middle
of my day i was an out of control person
back in those days meaning this i woke
up worried stressed fearful and i
immediately start thinking about a bill
i had to pay something that was wrong
and i'm in a state of reaction to begin
every i'm talking within six minutes of
waking up six seconds most people listen
to this that's what they do i said i
gotta grab control of my morning and i
set up routines in my morning
maybe they served me maybe they didn't
but they were things i could deliver on
doing for myself and so not only did
that give me control over the day but i
started to stack my self-confidence too
my morning routines are really detailed
um i get up and i hydrate the second
thing i do every morning is i do
something cold
something cold so whether that's i jump
in the ocean because now i live in the
ocean but in those days it was taking a
cold shower or splashing some cold water
on my face or walking out when it was
cold it shocks our nervous system our
fight or flight kicks in we're at a
cellular electric alive state i
obviously do some prayer and meditation
every single morning i've still not
touched my telephone so there's a rule
there's 30 minutes i cannot touch my
telephone when i wake up that's the
hardest thing to do in the world and the
thing that could benefit you the most
because what's ever on that phone you
have to react to and typically it's
stuff that's not great and so i don't
touch that i do my meditation and my
prayer and i do some stretching i do
some breathing exercises and then at
that point i allow myself to enter the
world after i've got my state controlled
and habit number seven the last one
before some very special bonus clips is
hack your decision-making process with
bob proctor if you turn making a
decision into a habit you're going to
learn how to do a whole lot of things
you may think you can't do
see
what we're doing is we're exploring a
side of our personality that we really
don't understand
now
i photographed a page out of here
napoleon hill said those who reach
decisions promptly and definitely know
what they want and they generally get it
the leaders in every walk of life decide
quickly and firmly that's the major
reason why they're leaders he said the
world is the habit of making room for
the man or woman whose words and actions
show they know where they're going and
he went on to explain why we have
difficulty here for very good reason
indecision is a habit
which usually begins in youth the habit
takes on permanency as the youth goes
through grade school high school
eventually through college without any
definite purpose the major weakness of
all educational systems is they neither
teach nor encourage the habit of
definite decision do you know the reason
most people don't make decisions because
they can't see how they're going to get
there
so what do they do they keep doing
things that they can see how they're
going to get there and that's why their
life never really changes
i've compiled the best of the best
together to find the seven best habits
that you want to do to succeed in your
life
[Music]
habit number one is ignore the little
man so many people i talked to at that
time for alipay they say this is the
stupidest idea you have ever got my
father he said this is an embarrassment
to me and was dumping all over me i
think every time i say i'm about to do
something people are waiting for me to
fumble i just can't live my life based
upon what other people think about me
everybody told me you don't need to do
that man some people would rather kill
your dream than see you succeed oh you
don't understand how hard it is to make
it brendan it's so hard these days
everybody told me you're nuts you can't
do that you can't do that and the people
who are like offended by it it doesn't
matter don't ever let somebody tell you
you can't do something along your path
to success you're going to have a lot of
people who tell you that what you want
to do is not possible that it's just
never going to happen for you that you
don't have the skills the talent the
abilities the drive the money the
resources the connections whatever it is
and some of those people will just be
jealous straight up they'll be jealous
maybe they had a dream that they wanted
to chase and they weren't able to do it
and so now nobody around them is allowed
to be successful they're going to try to
always pull you down to their level
that's definitely going to be a chunk
some of the people who hate on your
ideas and they're the little man
they love you they're your parents
they're your friends they just see
success through their eyes so success
for that person may be having a safe
steady corporate job for your entire
life that's success and doing anything
else
that's risky that's dangerous you
shouldn't go and do that and so they
want you to live their life and that's
their way of showing you love and so at
some point in your life you need to
figure out if you're going to live your
version of your life or somebody else's
version whether you're going to live up
to your own expectations or you're
living for somebody else's expectations
and when you have that self-confidence
to say i'm living my version of my life
than anybody else who's just trying to
knock your idea down not the ones who
give you feedback not the ones that say
hey here's how you can make it better
it's not just you have all the answers
but the people are just hating on your
idea and telling you you can't do it
successful people ignore the little man
[Music]
habit number two is think big
think big think big big thinking big
thinking really big think bigger go big
think big dream big one of the things
that i've seen consistently in the
habits of successful people successful
entrepreneurs is that they don't limit
their thinking this ties to the last
point about the little man we have this
vision for what we want to accomplish a
vision what we think is possible the
more that you can expand that vision the
more that you can think about having a
bigger impact to take that little idea
that you have that may be a huge idea
for your community right like it may be
the biggest thing ever done in your
family or in your city
and you want to take it even bigger the
people who have the most success the
people who have the biggest impact
they're thinking on a different scale
they're thinking on a bigger scale
that's part of why i made this series i
made the top 10 series i made the mentor
me series all of these videos is because
i want to be surrounded by people who
are thinking bigger to help push me to
think beyond my comfort zone because i
think for a lot of entrepreneurs you're
surrounded by people who are small
thinking and they may even say hey
you're doing such a great job you know
look at all that great work that you're
doing look at that big vision you have
and nobody's saying listen you're doing
an okay job like this is really good but
you could be playing out here
you're still playing small you got to
expand your vision you got to expand
your horizon and successful people think
bigger and so i'd encourage you to look
at is your vision big enough and when
you have those moments of boldness where
you want to be out here do you then have
the environment around you to support
that big thinking on a consistent basis
every single day not just one day all
excited and then fall back down and the
next month one day all excited and fall
back down consistently think big
[Music]
habit number three is no excuses you're
just making excuses don't pick on
excuses you can find opportunities don't
accept excuses well we've got no time
for excuses and i'll have an excuse no
excuses no excuses my friends no longer
wallow
in my self-pity successful people don't
make excuses it's so easy to make
excuses most people
blame somebody else for why they're not
successful right it's the president's
fault it's my country's fault it's the
education system's fault it's my parents
fault it's my friend's fault it's it's
my bank's fault it's always somebody
else's fault right it's easy and it's so
it's always easy to put the blame on
somebody else because it makes you feel
good because accepting responsibility
sucks saying that your business is not
more successful because of the customers
or the economy or whatever it is it's so
much easier because it makes you feel
good but it keeps you where you are and
successful people the consistent habit
that they have is they accept
responsibility and don't make excuses
your business is where you are because
of you
your life is where it's at because of
you your bank account is the size of
your bank account because of you
and when you accept that
at the start it sucks right to say like
this really sucks if this really because
of me man i suck
but it's also empowering because you
have the ability to change it you don't
need to wait another x number of years
for a new president to come in you don't
need to wait an x number of years for
the economy to get better you need to
wait for anything you just gotta get on
yourself and go make a change
successful people don't make excuses
[Music]
habit number four is work hard work work
work work work work work work work work
work hard work working hard work hard
hard work work harder work hard hard
work hard work for all the people out
there who are trying to build a passive
income and are trying to work smart what
you need to do is both you need to work
smart and work hard if you look at the
people who've had the most success in
whatever field whether it's in
entrepreneurship or whether it's at a
relationship or it's whether it's being
a parent you want to be a good parent
you have to work hard at it you can't
put being a parent on autopilot and make
it a passive thing that just happens and
expect to be a good parent right you
can't put your business on autopilot and
expect to be a great entrepreneur
whatever your goal is whether it's
financial whether it's spiritual whether
it's in the family whether it's with
your business whatever the impact you
want to have whatever your big goal is
you need to work at it you need to work
smart and you need to work hard you got
to wake up every day and and go after
the torture that you enjoy the thing
that when people look at your schedule
they say that's crazy how can you work
so hard but for you you do it because
you want to because you have an end goal
and so you have to be willing and able
to put in the hours required to become
really great at something
in whatever field again that you have
your goal set up you need to work hard
[Music]
habit number five is follow your passion
passion passion passion passion passion
passion
passion passion passion passion passion
passion passion passion past passion
passion passion this ties in with
working hard you only will really work
hard and put in the hours at something
that you love doing you look at the top
people in any field they love the work
that they're doing they love it they do
the torture because it's not torture for
them they love the work so many people
are attached just to a goal i need to
make this much money right i want to go
buy that car whatever it is i'll do
whatever it takes to get there you won't
do whatever it takes because that goal
itself is not important enough because
the work itself if you hate doing the
work
you're never going to become a success
you're going to quit you're going to
give because it's hard
if it's anything worth doing it's going
to be hard it's going to be a lot of
work and the people who love it who
don't see the work as work will keep
going
how many videos do i make a week how
many
i make so many videos a week
i do it because i like making videos you
will not be able to keep up with my
schedule of making videos because you
don't love it as much most people don't
love it as much maybe you're the rare
person who loves video even more than me
and that's amazing i'd love to meet you
but whatever your goal is
it's great having that end goal you need
to enjoy the process successful people
enjoy the day-to-day grind of what they
do because they don't see it as a grind
that doesn't mean that every day is
amazing and happy and all you're doing
is work that you enjoy there's a lot of
crap that comes with it
being a parent there's a lot of crap
that comes with being a parent but you
got to do the work you got to put in the
time you got to love your kids if you
want to be a great parent and there's
the reward is definitely worth it over
the pain that comes with it and some of
the down days that you'll have but
successful people follow their passion
[Music]
habit number six is gratitude i always
felt grateful for even the small things
grateful be grateful grateful be
grateful be grateful be grateful i think
it's important that you are grateful for
the things in your life i think
entrepreneurs need to be equally
grateful for what they have and wanting
to do more you know i look at if my
channel ends today i'd be really proud
of everything i have i love the life
that i have the friends that i have the
family i have the business that i have i
love it all and at the same time i want
to go out and do more because i know i
have the ability to do more i want to
reach more people i want to touch more
lives i think too many entrepreneurs are
just so focused on more and more more it
becomes this endless chase because you
never get there whatever wherever you
get is going to always be more and
always want to be more and that drive is
amazing
and entrepreneurs have that in spades
just spending some time being grateful
for what you do actually have
can help balance you out and make you a
much happier entrepreneur and i think
it's needed if you want to have success
that gratitude part i think is important
i've had a success practice in my life
for a number of years it used to be
i had a pad of paper by my bed and i
woke up every morning wrote down three
things i'm grateful for i evolved that
into something i do with my team where
every day they share something we all
share something in a private facebook
group that we're grateful for for the
day it also helps you get to know your
team members a little bit more and makes
you realize things that
maybe you should be grateful for too if
someone on my team says they're grateful
for the sun today you know i'm like i
look at the sun today i'm grateful for
the sun too and add some extra awareness
for you and now we do it you know on the
channel we've had live gratitude
sessions as well whatever your practice
is making it a daily thing where you're
grateful for what you have as well as
being driven to want to do more is an
important habit for a lot of successful
entrepreneurs
[Music]
and number seven is believe believe
believe believably
believe
so you guys know if you've got made it
to the end of this video if you watch
any of the videos on my channel you know
i'm all about believe i think it's the
core of success in a lot of
entrepreneurs you have to believe in the
work that you're doing you have to
believe in yourself that you can go and
do it and you have to believe that it's
going to work out and successful people
have that belief in themselves that they
can do it and not all the time because
everybody thinks about quitting at some
point and that may mean you need to
watch a video or read a book or be
around friends that can help you build
you back up to get to the point where
you have the confidence to go and
continue to do it but you need to
believe in what you're doing believe in
yourself and believe that it's going to
work out and i would challenge you that
if you are that person to then not just
settle for that but also be the spark
for other people if you see somebody
else who needs a little bit of belief in
themselves and belief in their work just
saying i believe in you without being
able to give them advice somebody wants
to
you know start a makeup line and you
know nothing about makeup just giving
them a little bit of a boost and say you
know what i believe that you can do that
you're really talented i think you'll
make it just a little bit
can be the difference how many times
have you had somebody say to you have
you got a minute but
you got a minute
they don't want a minute
i want you to think about that
i read a poem one time i said i have
only just a minute
only 60 seconds in it
it was forced upon me i can't refuse it
i didn't seek it and i didn't choose it
but it's up to me to use it i must
suffer if i lose it give a count if i
abuse it it's only a tiny little minute
but eternity is in it
well anyway i thought i'm going to put
this on a video and i'm just going to
share with everybody just this one
little part of the seminar i'm making
i want you to look at this sand timer
and let this i want you to think about
your life the sand in the top of the
glass represents the future the sand in
the bottom of the glass represents the
past
now do you know we know it's in the past
and yet we can't do anything about it do
you know what the trick is you don't
know how much sands in the top of the
glass you may think you have a lot you
might only have a little
then again you may think you have a
little and you might have a lot
when i was a little boy i was raised by
my grandmother
and i don't know when i was little
gaffer she was probably 60 but
as long as i can remember grandma would
say and i'll soon be glad here i'll soon
be gone well you know we loved her she
was really an angel of god but we
thought she was never going to go she
lived to be 94 for 30 some years
i'll soon be gone
she didn't think she had much time left
she had 34 years left
now about the same time i had a buddy of
mine bob yates he was just 16.
and bang he run into the abutment of a
bridge and his life was snuffed out
if you had asked him a half hour before
how much sandy had left he would have
said at least a half a century he didn't
have a half an hour
see the trick is we don't know how much
sand we have left
the future
we don't know
the past it's gone now the only thing
you can deal with is what's right here
right now and if you look the sand is
always moving
now think of this
you see i was working on that and then i
was working on a graph i've got here on
my computer
and i'm thinking of the time somebody
said have you got a minute
well they don't really want a minute
do you know if you're earning 50 000 a
year in minutes 42 cents a half hour is
12.50
if we take that ahead of it if you're
earning 80 000 a year a minute 67 cents
half hour's 20
if you're earning a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars a year got a minute
it cost you a dollar twenty five a
minute
a half hour's 37 dollars and fifty cents
so do you see if somebody said you want
to stop for a cup of coffee
well if you're earning a quarter of a
million dollars a year
a minute is two dollars and eight cents
half hour is 62.50
and then of course you've got the coffee
to pay for on top of that so you see
the point is this
this is all we've got right here right
now we don't know how much we have left
in the future but we do know what we've
got now and i have found the people that
win
are the people who make up their mind
they're not going to waste the minutes
they're going to be productive they're
going to make it happen
every minute i went from scrounging my
couch cushions to find enough change to
put gas in my car
to helping build this technology company
i was hired as a copywriter and i worked
my way up i became a multi-millionaire
inside that company on paper
and i was
miserable
miserable
and i thought this is a joke i'm living
the cliche of money camp by happiness
what how many people had to say it and i
still didn't believe it like how many
people literally have to tell you money
is not going to give you the thing you
want i've had every opportunity up here
to be like yeah let's get rich
that [ __ ] is cool as hell
and here's the thing people will chase
money forever why because it's real
money is real money is powerful
but money's not at all what you think it
is you think when it comes to success
like getting there making it achieving
it the way that you see somebody that's
achieved it now however you define that
and you look at them and you think oh my
god they're amazing you think you're
going to think the same thing about
yourself
and you won't
and i had the very good fortune my
wealth came all at once
i built a company i had tons of equity
in the company i was worth hundreds of
millions of dollars on paper but i was
still driving a beat up car and my life
was whatever i was in a normal house i
was making a good salary no need to feel
sorry for me but in terms of like
the wealth moment it literally came in
an instant
it was all right guys the money's been
wired
and you hit refresh on your bank account
refresh refresher faster faster faster
faster fast and then bam you're crazy
rich and it's like
commas and zeros and you're like holy sh
i don't feel any differently about
myself
and all of my insecurities all the
things that i beat myself up for all of
it still right here it literally didn't
change anything i could buy neater stuff
but the only thing like if you want to
know what money really does
money lets you build
i'm building impact theory i'm going to
win
because i have the intensity and i have
the capital
that's money but money doesn't touch who
you are so my thing is i may go broke
building
impact theory that that is a reality
because i know the struggle's guaranteed
the success isn't
so it's very possible i'm betting my
fortune right now
on building this thing maybe doesn't
work
but that won't touch how i feel about
myself
losing the money won't touch how i feel
about myself any more than making the
money couldn't touch how i felt about
myself because you either do the
internal work of like i know who i am
the thing that you'll resent
isn't whether or not you make it
the thing that you'll resent is now that
you know you can will you actually try
trying is what you're going to judge
yourself on
hey don't cheer on that that [ __ ] is
scary that's the one i want you guys to
think about today
because none of you
your family won't weep for you if you
don't succeed
two things will happen on your deathbed
if you failed you really went for
something and you failed
one
they will all mourn
that you weren't able to live your life
because you were so myopically focused
on the goal
that you forgot to enjoy the journey
and somewhere along the way you stopped
loving you stopped loving them you
stopped loving yourself because all you
could see
was succeeding getting that thing the
tick on the paper box
and you lost your way that's possibility
number one
possibility number two
is they're like hey
this
tried and it was inspiring and just to
see them go
day after day after day in the face of
so much defeat but to have the will and
determination to keep going
winston churchill said and i quote
success is
going from failure
to failure to failure
without a loss of enthusiasm
it doesn't matter if you win that's not
success
the success is going from the failure to
the failure to the failure and still
being excited to show up
it's like this is how i liken success
success is like love you know the
beautiful part about love getting the
[ __ ] kicked out of you and then
coming back for more
that's so hopeful that's so optimistic
to be like whoa i just had my ass handed
to me and yet i want to be vulnerable
again i want to go through this again i
want to open myself up to this i want to
be touched by that i want to feel that
people can get behind that man we can
get excited about that
we want to be friends with people like
that we want to feel that in our own
lives that willingness to to have tasted
defeat
and still come in open and not jaded how
beautiful is that there are many aspects
to this fundamentally if you keep your
life energies very exuberant
now you will see the sleep quota will
naturally come down to keep it exuberant
you should not be overleading
largely in the ashram everybody young
people also eat only two meals a day ten
in the morning seven in the evening
our activity
exceeds most people's activity in the
world
and we are seven days 365 days we don't
know what's a vacation
because we're enjoying what we're doing
we don't want a break
so
they never go on a vacation there is no
break there's no sunday monday nonsense
nothing every day something is happening
endlessly
but you will see
people are very energetic healthy sleep
is very little
so energetically a human being can be at
different levels why this is important
is
see what we call as life is just a
combination of two things
a certain amount of energy and a certain
amount of time
when it comes to time
it is ticking away for all of us at the
same pace clock doesn't run slowly for
me faster for you there's no such thing
whether you are busy you are lazy you
are sleeping you are doing useful things
or useless things it doesn't matter what
you do or you do not do
time is ticking away
so there is no such thing as time
management
you can manage your energy
if you raise your energy to a higher
pitch of intensity
what somebody does in 10 years you may
do it in one year
so if you live for 100 years it looks
like you lived for a thousand years
simply because your energy is pitched up
this every human being can do
the whole yogic system is one dimension
of yogic system is just towards this if
you sit here even if you simply sit here
with your eyes closed you don't sit here
in a static way
you sit here in a dynamic way
you never become static because static
is called as death
if everything becomes static that is
death
if inertia really sets in that is death
so sleep in yoga is seen as death
you die every day
how long do you want to die in a day
you really must use this word for
yourself don't tell anybody i'm going to
die
for yourself how long do i want to die
in a day
eight hours a day if you die
one third of your life you're dead
in 24 hours eight hours you're dead
means one third of your life dead
another four hours goes into eating
sleeping eating toilet bath this that
where is the time to live i'm asking
so if life is precious
the most important thing to do is keep
your energies in an exuberant way so
that
life becomes more life feels enhanced
because you cannot enhance time every
day we recharge our phones but we forget
to recharge ourselves
let's just say we slept well the night
before which means we start our day with
a hundred percent charge
when we wake up in the morning we roll
over and 80 of us check our smartphones
before we brush our teeth we scroll
through social media we browse through
emails
that takes away 10 percent of our energy
let's say we now have 90
charge left we then commute to work we
spend our day in the office in meetings
interacting with colleagues finishing
off projects and assignments
we now have 40
charge left
on the way home we commute through
traffic or on the train and that takes
away another let's say 10
we now have 30
charge left we come home and switch on
netflix talk to someone about what our
day was like
and sometimes we lose another 10 percent
we now have 20
charge left at 20 on our phones usually
the charge bar goes red we get an alert
we get a message that tells us that we
only have 20
battery left the question is do we
notice when our charge is at 20 percent
or 10 percent there are always signs
from our bodies our brains our minds but
are we tuned in one of the best things
we can do to recharge is to exercise the
hardest part of any workout is actually
the 15 minutes leading up to it we come
up with 15 reasons why we don't want to
sweat and we change our mind 15
different times cnn reports that when
you work out your brain creates more
serotonin which sends messages to your
nervous system of happiness and
well-being working out for 30 to 40
minutes every day can recharge our
battery by 20
meditation is an incredible way to
recharge our batteries exactly what the
gym does for the body meditation can do
for the mind
meditation gives us down time physically
mentally emotionally and spiritually
meditation also directly impacts your
entire nervous system by reducing your
body's productions of stress-related
chemicals such as cortisol
meditation is a great way to recharge
and can take you back up 20 percent
we've all heard about incredible morning
routines but the one thing that can make
a huge difference to your recharge is
your evening routine 35 of us are not
getting the recommended seven hours of
sleep per night
remember every body and mind is
different make sure you find the amount
of time you need to get that serious
battery recharge and the 75-year study
by harvard found that beyond anything
the real sense check for happiness and
meaning in life
was relationships connections
interactions with depth that are
fulfilling and full of joy making time
for deep meaningful interactions every
day can give the recharge our battery
seriously needs
what if we've recharged ourselves
as much as we recharge our phones
because if we don't we'll end up like
one of our phones
in the bottom of some drawer in our home
my thing is how do we stay alive long
enough to give time for these step
function breakthroughs to happen so what
do i do like what are the things that i
train or the hormone replacement
therapies that i need to go what do i
need to watch what are those things that
i should be doing
taking a step back i would say three
years ago 80 to 90 of my energy went
into how to not die
which basically strategy yeah which is
tantamount to how do you delay the onset
of chronic disease so the mathematical
equivalent of longevity from a lifespan
perspective is creating a phase shift in
disease onset
if you want to live to hundred
it basically means you have to delay the
onset by about two decades of every
major chronic disease so it doesn't mean
you can't get cancer or heart disease or
any of these other things but you better
figure out a way to get them 20 years
after the average person gets them
i would say now that occupies 50 of my
brain wave energy whatever and much more
time goes into two other things which is
how to minimize suffering which is kind
of an emotional problem and then how to
be this kick-ass 100 year old so to the
latter
um
the model i have in my mind is that of
sort of bruce lee bruce lee
sort of looked at each and every
discipline of martial arts including
boxing and wrestling and things like
that and said
let me extract from each of these
disciplines that which i believe is
useful discard those that i think are
useless and create a perfect fighting
form that is truly geared towards
self-defense so it is not a sport there
is no tournament there is no rank there
is no belt there is no sensei it is can
you handle yourself in a life or death
situation
if i go to a yoga class
or if i do a pilates class invariably
there's something in there that i think
is really valuable and truthfully
there's a bunch of stuff that i'm like i
don't need this this is just if i had
infinite time this would be fine to do
but i don't have infinite time
so now you apply a constraint to the
problem which is not only do you want to
be sort of the best 100 year old
imaginable what if you're only willing
to spend 10 to 12 hours a week preparing
for that
and so you say okay well so there's a
new sport which we defined some of the
parameters of that's your new olympics
and that olympics is 50 years from now
how will you train for it if you're only
willing to spend 10 to 12 hours a week
training for it
well my guess is you will take a lot of
things
from various disciplines discard a lot
of things and sort of have to build a
very bespoke
routine around it that will involve the
maintenance of muscle mass joint
integrity flexibility
functional movement balance things that
we don't even really think about anymore
how many times does someone who's 90
fall because they've lost their balance
and it's that fall that ultimately leads
to their demise i have this thing that
i've been promoting called no whining
wednesdays
wednesday you cannot whine
complain or criticize
and people like well what is wine and
whatever you think it is don't do it
and every time you do it you have to put
a quarter in a jar
if you whine about anything i can't i'm
tired writing me one why don't you
whatever
every one of them will cost you a
quarter
or complaining why don't you why do you
always how come you i always they never
cost you a quarter then last week i had
people send me pictures of their jaws a
quarters
oh my god
but what they said to me also was this
was wonderful because i was never ever
aware
of how much whining and complaining and
criticizing i do
now i've got mothers
doing it with their children
so wednesday is no whining wednesday
we need to practice that
we need to stop whining
about what isn't happening what we don't
have what we can't do what somebody
didn't do
we got to get it clean in 2014.
no whining
no complaining
no criticizing i made it a habit to
listen as much as i could
and because i have many great mentors
i would
understand from them that the way they
built their lives they built their
careers also came from this listening
so i started listening and what i
started to find is that very often
the messages don't just come from an
intuitive impulse or an insight it comes
from a random person whom we meet on the
street or it comes from a random
conversation here in this room or it
comes from a book that we pick up in the
morning
literally some of the ideas i'm going to
share from stage today came from these
random encounters over the last 24 hours
i'm going to share an idea that came
from a book today like a really thick
book that a friend gave me last night
i asked the universe is there a message
in this book that i should share with
the audience i open the page and boom
there it was
and the basis for this talk came from a
mysterious phone call that came to me
yesterday morning so yesterday morning i
was brushing my teeth
and i was asking myself
what do i talk about 24 hours from now
on stage
and i didn't want to just
tap into my logical brain and look at my
file of like some 50 different regular
presentations i thought maybe i'll just
go take the elevator down randomly roam
the lobby and wait for one of you guys
to approach me and ask me a question
carry out a conversation and see what
happens because that's how the universe
sometimes speaks to you
right
the universe doesn't have whatsapp so it
basically like manipulates people that
come into your life i try to be over
prepared in some sense so i mean i
believe that if you're going to if
you're going to give a 20 minute lecture
you should have an hour of material at
hand because that way you have an
opportunity to sort of move
spontaneously through the material but
generally what i do now because i have a
lot of material
at hand a lot of stories and a lot of
things that i've acknowledged say that
i've accrued over the years usually
before a lecture also and this is the
hard part and i can do a lecture without
doing this but it's better if i do this
this is the hard part i'll sit down for
20 minutes with my eyes closed
and i figure out what the what the
central topic is so there's always a
question what's the question i'm trying
to address in this lecture
and then i'll figure out a pathway
through it it's like okay well here's
the argument here's point one here's
point two here's point three and there's
possible branches off those and then
with each point i usually have a
collection of stories and facts that i
can use to
make the point that that's the point
yeah yeah and then to buttress it and to
make it interesting and so it's a little
bit it's a little bit like improvisation
jazz i would say or even improvisational
piano because i play a little bit of
piano one so you lay out the the story
and then right you can use the responses
of the audience to guide how you're
going to walk through it
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing habits that will change
your year check the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there we have research to show that 60
days of meditation
five days a week will lengthen your life
the telomeres the little shoestrings on
the end of your dna get longer
that means